wait yep
foreign
okay hello there welcome to another
episode of Science and Technology q a
for kids and others and let's see uh
what kind of interesting questions have
come in here
um
question from Mikhail here is there a
scientific approach to simulating
society what are the main laws in
sociology
interesting you know there's there's a
question of are there kind of scientific
laws that determine features of human
behavior and at times in history people
have been more or less convinced that
there aren't I mean in in um famously
around uh well the the big sort of
growth of mathematical science that
happened in the late 1600s with Newton
and Friends made people say wow you can
write down mathematical formulas for all
kinds of stuff like orbits of planets
and things like this maybe people
thought you can write down mathematical
formulas for uh all kinds of things in
the world and things like the universal
law of gravity the inverse Square law of
gravity might apply to all kinds of
things whether it be things about
planets or things about people and by
probably around 1800 there was this kind
of idea that there might be sort of a
social physics that would be kind of an
analog of something like Newtonian
physics of formulas for behavior that
would govern kind of the structure of
society
despite efforts to make this work it
never really did and there'd been a
whole series of kind of attempts to say
well there's there's sort of two ends to
this there's the there's the let's
describe how Society should work
and then let's try and describe how
Society kind of uh does work and what
empirical laws there might be for that
and in terms of the how Society should
work well that's the story of Marxism
and lots of other kinds of of efforts
like that where where people were kind
of along the lines of uh we can uh we
can describe we can set up Society to be
kind of a mechanical control system a
little bit like we do in machines and
then everything will work perfectly uh
turns out it usually didn't
um and uh there are lots of spectacular
and horrifying examples of that
um but uh and one of the features of
that is sort of things that you don't
expect always seem to happen but that's
sort of branch number one is let's set
up Society to be machine like so that we
can predict how it works and control
what's going on branch number two has
tended to be let's just try and observe
society as it is and try and deduce
empirical laws for how it might work
and I would say that that has been also
somewhat uh
unconvincingly successful so to speak I
mean if we ask what are some laws that
people have noticed you know there's a
whole collection of laws that are
so-called power laws so if you ask a
question like
um what is the if if you rank all cities
in a country in order of their size from
the largest to the smallest if you rank
all companies from largest to smallest
if you rank kind of incomes from the
largest to the smallest and so on what
is the chance the the nth most uh nth
highest ranked thing what fraction of
the maximum is that and it's pretty
common to find that the fraction is
something like 1 over n or one over n to
some power and so that leads one to this
idea that there may be kind of power
laws that determine kind of the the
frequency of something like the nth
largest city might be of size let's say
one over N I don't think it is quite
that in in words for example as famous
things so-called Zips law that says that
the nth most common word in English has
frequency about one over n so there are
a whole collection of these so-called
power laws sometimes one knows what
leads to them sometimes one doesn't
sometimes they're not really as real as
people might think they were and they
only apply over some very small range of
of values and so on
but that's some and sometimes the reason
for power laws is something rather
structural like for example uh a thing
keeps on breaking into sub-pieces and
and that sort of breaking into sub
pieces thing uh leads one to a
distribution of of numbers of copies of
the thing that corresponds to this power
law but that that's been one sort of uh
uh lore of society that people identify
now people have tried to uh make kind of
more more Global laws I think that the
um uh the the tendency
well okay so economics is kind of an
area where much work has been done along
these lines and you know econometrics is
kind of the the branch of economics in
which one is kind of trying to look at
numerical quantities that determine kind
of economic behavior you know I had this
experience I think I probably told the
story before but I had this experience
back in the late 1980s uh when
mathematical Muslim language were first
out of visiting uh different kinds of
customers we had and it happened in in
one week or so period to visit both the
Federal Reserve in Washington DC and the
Russian Central economic planning Bureau
in Moscow
and what was interesting was the the the
the the interests that those different
groups had in the technology that we
provided the folks in Washington DC were
all about statistics they were all about
we observe what's happening in the
economic world and we try and make kind
of statistical inferences we try and say
the average of this is this the uh the
the variation of this is this and so on
and we try and make kind of models that
are statistical probabilistic models of
what's going on that was their interest
the um on the on the Moscow side the
interest was all in linear programming
that is if you have a certain set of
constraints that say this this plus this
is less than that and so on how do you
solve those constraints how do you set
up a kind of organized controlled system
uh for um uh
for economics
um I I have to say a few years earlier
when I visited when was uh still the
Soviet Union
um it was uh it was notable the person
who was my assigned guide was
complaining about the fact that um uh
they'd had um you know a refrigerator
Factory where they'd been making
refrigerators for seven years in a
single refrigerator made that had ever
worked and um it was sort of interesting
to hear the the the horrors of a then
failing uh kind of system of controls
for an economic setup but any case the
um
you know I think the question that that
arises in economics is a particularly
notable case where there really is
quantitative data to be had
um where you can start asking questions
about sort of you know are there models
for what's going on I think this this
question of can you make models for how
things work when there are human systems
it's an interesting question and I think
the answer is yes you can make models
but they're not necessarily models for
things that are the things that will be
most immediately useful in terms of uh
what one wants to do in the world so to
speak so to fill that in a little bit
more one of the a couple of things to
say one place where I've certainly seen
sort of laws of human behavior show up
is in web analytics you know you look at
all these people visiting wolfen Alpha
all these people visiting our websites
and so on
um you'll see all sorts of detailed
curves of you know what's the what's the
probability for some somebody who's
clicked one link to click another link
how long does it take them to click that
link what's the probability what's the
way that that people kind of go through
the network that represents a website
with all of its um uh with all its
hyperlinks and so on and how do people
kind of diffuse through that uh through
that network and to what extent can one
kind of describe uh those things by some
sort of physical type process
um I think that um
uh one thing that's notable about things
like web analytics is how smooth the
curves are one thing that's also notable
is nobody knows why the curves look like
that that there are definite you know
forms of you know the the uh you know
inter-query intervals and so on they
form a definite distribution it's pretty
constant and it has been I think I
haven't looked at it recently but for
for years it was a very constant thing
in wolfen Alpha for example all those
millions and millions of people you know
just typing things and yet the aggregate
distribution was surprisingly
predictable
now you know the question is why does
something like that happen well there
are things that come out of sort of pure
statistics there are sort of
mathematical results so notable one is
the central limit theorem which
basically says that if you have a bunch
of randomly picked numbers where the
numbers are let's say picked in the
interval zero to one and uh you just
pick these numbers and you add about
five of them or a bit more together and
you take the average of those those five
numbers the distribution of the average
is usually very close to a gaussian
distribution a a bell-shaped uh
distribution that's a result that is
true regardless of what the details of
that distribution of original numbers
are and so that's essentially
mathematically derived uh distributional
results it's not always true but it's
true in many cases and that's a case
where where you get something like that
another
type of thing there are features of kind
of us humans that are things like oh
there are laws what is it affectionate
law is that right to the the um the law
that says that uh uh things tend to be
sort of logarithmically we notice things
logarithmically if you are sort of
um
if you put I don't know twice as much
pressure on press something twice as
hard or if you have twice as loud a
noise or something like this that what
matters is the uh the logarithm of the
actual intensity of the Sound by that I
mean if you double the intensity of the
sound it's like you're going up by one
unit rather than doubling the intensity
meaning it's going up it's it seems like
double so to speak that's why for
example our our scale of a measuring
sound with decibels and so on is a
logarithmic scale every time you go up
by one decibel corresponds to
multiplying the amount of Sound by a
factor
so uh yeah
so
I think um the uh
uh so so there are these so some laws
which seem to be specific to humans this
this tendency that is sort of the way
that our perception works of these kinds
of logarithmic Trends in our perception
that's a that's another example of
something like that I would say that the
um uh there are also questions
well people people discuss things like
the organization of society and the fact
that there is a tendency to have some
hierarchical organizations to humans to
human society and so on and uh that's
something that seems to be sort of a
universally emergent thing you know I'm
amused in in companies for example it's
pretty common there's a CEO and then
there are a bunch of people who report
to the CEO and then more people to
report to each of them and so on you
have this kind of hierarchical tree
structure to the company and that's a
you know pretty common setup for whether
it's in governments or armies or or lots
of other kinds of things occasionally
people try and do experiments on
different approaches there's one called
the ideas called holocracy and the idea
of a hypocrisy is that instead of having
a hierarchical structure for a company
you will have the company organized in a
collection of kind of intersecting
circles where you have collections of
people who are kind of reviewing what
each other are doing but nobody's in
charge or anybody else
the uh so far as I know the empirical
efforts to actually do that in practice
with real humans have been rather
horrifyingly unsuccessful
um and uh that perhaps tells one
something about the fact that there is
some natural tendency to have uh some
sort of hierarchical structure to
organizations if you want them to
operate and perhaps that's a feature of
sort of a necessary feature of
organizations and the definition of what
it means for an organization to be
organized and to try and Achieve
objectives as an organization or perhaps
that's more a reflection of something
about us as humans you know people talk
about other kinds of General features of
of humans like you know you can have
someone what is it 80 or something
a number of people who are sort of in
your in your social uh milia and and
that um there's a there's a certain
friend distribution you know I remember
many years ago when when Facebook's API
was more open probably more so than it
should have been
um we did a project where people could
connect with malfo to their Facebook
apis and get kind of personal analytics
data on
uh their kind of Facebook world so to
speak
and one thing that we did there was we
kept some anonymized data about a very
large number of people in the end uh
Facebook profiles
um and I don't remember all the results
here but I do remember that there was a
certain distribution of how many friends
people have and I I vaguely remember
that the peak of the distribution was in
the few hundred range it was also
interesting to see if you looked at the
age distribution of the friends of
people you would find that that people
usually were friends mostly with people
very close to their own age until they
got to be 40 something years old and
then there would be a little extra Peak
uh at the youngest end which was
probably the people being friends with
the their children or their children's
friends and so on so you see kind of
things like that that look very uh kind
of quite structured and so on but
you know on a general level this
question of of how predictable is kind
of uh what happens with humans and so on
um how predictable is uh uh you can also
ask them how predictable is what happens
with history
um you know are there things about kind
of human society that are things that
are necessary by the nature of kind of
organizing a society are there things
that are accidents of the particular
history of of human society as it's
growing up and so on and how can you
could have teased those things apart one
of the things that I've come to to think
is that this the things I've studied
about the way that sort of one thinks
about things computationally the the
model that one Imagines for humans that
is
a sort of plausible models are not
mathematical equations there isn't sort
of an equation typically for what a
person does but there might be a way to
represent a bit about what a person does
and terms of programs and to say you
know this with this set of inputs this
rule should be applied that will
determine what the person will do in a
sense that kind of setup is a one has a
an internal view that one is operating
according to certain kinds of rules
perhaps but also if we look at society
as a whole there are things like laws
and regulations and so on which
essentially work like that they say if
this or that happens then this or that
should happen and it looks very much
like a computer program except that it
tends to be written out at least in the
current time as a piece of kind of legal
statement in whatever language English
or whatever rather than a piece of of
Code by the way I mean in our efforts to
build our computational language our
open language system that sort of
represents the world computationally one
of the things that is an emerging kind
of opportunity there is to write things
which were contracts that were written
in English or legalese and write them in
computational language so that in fact
it becomes really the case that the
things that run the world are code and
the things that run the world that
should model how the world works at the
level of human laws and so on are things
that are computational doesn't
necessarily say that that determines how
an individual human will choose to to
act but it does tell you something about
how sort of the regulations
imposed by Society can be represented
computationally so then the question is
let's say you've got a world in which
the thing is pretty much run by code
it's it's run by you know computational
language
um the humans okay we can represent some
of what they're doing in terms of sort
of computational uh language programs
and things like this now we ask the
question so you've got millions of
humans that are all operating this way
they're sort of governments that operate
this way and impose rules and so on what
does that mean for how Society will
operate and so that then leads on to the
question of oh you've got these programs
running what will the programs do what
will the consequences of these programs
be one of the things that's been a big
result of my efforts work over the last
40 years or so has been this idea of
computational irreducibility this idea
that even when you know exactly what the
programs are that determine how a system
will work what the sort of low-level
rules are to figure out the consequences
of that for sort of the overall behavior
of the system is irreducibly hard you
pretty much just have to run the program
and see what happens so it's kind of
like when people write laws and things
like that they often talk about
um uh the um
uh sort of unintended consequences you
know you think you're writing a law that
uh will make it easier for the little
guys to win or whatever else it is but
actually there's an unintended
consequence that makes exactly the
opposite be what happens
and one of the things to realize about
computational irreducibility is it's
kind of cementing this idea that there
will always be unintended consequences
that you can't ever expect in the world
with the world operating in this sort of
computational way you can't expect to
give this kind of Slam Dunk we've solved
it we just give this one principle and
everything will work great I mean you
know this this sort of segues a bit into
things like AI ethics and so on
um it's always interesting that um you
know when Isaac Asimov was was writing
his his robotics science fiction stories
you know he defined these kind of Laws
of Robotics you know the first law I
think is you know a robot um won't harm
a human or through inaction let a human
come to harm and then there's sort of a
second law that the robot will do what
humans tell it to do unless that sort of
conflicts with the first law and then
Third Law the robot will try to preserve
itself unless it conflicts with these
other laws and of course asimov's own
stories were mostly an exploration of
just all the corner cases where those
laws as such as stated didn't work but
that was an example of you know you
think you've just sort of nailed it you
just got these these golden principles
the small set of principles that will
determine how things work that will
never work computational irreducibility
kind of tells you that what has been
seen in in human experience which is
that people make laws and then they say
well that law isn't quite right we've
got to patch that and make another law
and so on and so on and so on that that
is sort of an inevitable feature of the
way that the world is not something that
is just because we didn't find the
perfect law we didn't find the perfect
way to set Society up and so on
so anyway a few thoughts about um uh the
sort of um
sort of um theories for society I would
say one more thing which is that that um
one of the things that's come out of our
physics project is the following thing
that even when there is endless
computational irreducibility in the
underlying dynamics of a system like for
example we've got gas molecules bouncing
around in the room they Bounce Around in
some very complicated pattern that
pattern is undoubtedly computationally
irreducible yet there are certain
statements we can make about gas in the
room about its pressure its volume its
temperature and so on that are quite
easy to make they're quite simple
formulas and they don't depend on all of
that irreducibility what actually
happens is that irreducibility when when
we choose to look only at particular
things the fact that there is all that
irreducibility kind of Smooths out the
complexity of what's going on and we are
left when we look only at particular
things and with very simple conclusions
about relationships between let's say
pressure and volume and so on and I
suspect that there are probably similar
things that can be said about economics
or about sociology where there are even
though there is a sort of bed of
computational irreducibility that there
are statements that can be made about
Society for example that are in fact
computationally reducible that are
actually definite sort of fairly simple
laws the question is
all those laws laws that a human who is
observing society would care about it
could be the case that there's some law
I don't know what can I make up some law
that says
um the
um
when there's a series of um
different
I don't know interactions between humans
the distribution of times that the
humans will have this type of
interaction versus that will be this or
that
and you might say well that's nice but I
don't care it it
um now having said that
interesting question whether if there is
some predictability in something even if
it's a thing about what you didn't think
you cared maybe that predictability has
some consequence so for example if
you're doing if you're in the finance
business and you're you know you're
trying to win in the stock market or
something what matters is can you
predict just a little bit better than
the next guy which stock to buy which
stock to sell and so on and so if there
is something that is predictable in
society even if the thing that's
predictable is incredibly obscure and
something where you say I don't you know
I don't care about that doesn't doesn't
have an effect most of the time it could
still be the case that that thing you
can find some path to go from that
predictable thing to uh kind of the um
uh to something where you can buy and
sell stocks or whatever else and uh and
and make a giant Financial killing from
it so to speak so you know it's an
interesting potentiality from kind of
thinking about things in terms of kind
of the ideas that have come out of our
physics project which are all about sort
of how do you how do you connect
computational irreducibility of an
underlying system to predictability of
things that humans notice about a system
um anyway a few thoughts about kind of
um social uh
um theory of of the social World
um I mean I I do think there probably
are some sort of more some theories that
can be gotten I think probably studying
Virtual Worlds where there's sort of
telemetry about everything where you
potentially know every single sort of
pixel of what what happened so to speak
um that has the potential to to give one
an insight into uh how how people behave
in more detail than when we'll see by by
looking at um things well one doesn't
have as much as much data and where
there's a lot more sort of offline State
um going on
uh
okay let's see
radio commenting property rights a very
basic element of a society yes I think
so
um
it's them
uh
yeah I I it's an interesting question
what the axiomatic sort of basis of
society what you need to have to have
something like
society as we now know it
you know for example property rights
uh people say you know there are
indigenous peoples where the way
property rights work is very different
and where it's much more of a sort of
collective ownership thing I think it's
often very hard from outside a culture
or a society to know really what's going
on inside and to understand you know
whether where somebody says oh no they
don't have a notion of blah
um it's uh uh you know that's just
because we don't understand that notion
of blah
um and uh uh you know I think it's it's
it's complicated to kind of project
these things one to another but yes it
does seem interesting to understand to
what extent the you know what needed to
be invented in kind of the history of
our species for example to lead to
society as Society more or less is today
I mean you know the idea of we are kind
of a tribal species of some in some
sense
um you know that who knows whether that
has I think probably has more uh
biological Origins than anything else
but that's something that drives lots of
kind of societal structure and you know
there are also things which are probably
features of
sort of necessary structural features of
systems like there has to be a leader to
things you know you've got a flock of
birds you've got a school of fish you
know in the end there's got to be a fish
that changes direction to decide the
school of fish is going to change
direction now you know you can decide is
it the elected fish leader or is it uh
you know a different fish every every
two minutes or what is it but there's
still got to be a lead fish so to speak
and um uh you know whether that's a
feature of presumably I mean presumably
otherwise you've got the sort of random
mass of fish where nobody knows where
anybody's going so to speak and that is
something which sort of is a necessary
feature to emerge I suspect
um but it is interesting to understand
to what extent sort of society has you
know what are the drivers of the way
Society works for example the fact that
there are you know parents and children
and things like this the fact that
they're finite lifespans the fact that
there are uh sort of there's there's
competition for resources and things to
what extent are these things the drivers
how in how much detail do they drive the
structure of society and if you remove
those kinds of things like you say
there's no competition for resources
it's hard to see how that really works
because in a sense whatever uh you know
there's there's always some kind of
resource it's always like well you know
I'm I'm the one who's going to hang out
at the top of the hill or I'm the one
who's going to have access to this
particular individual or whatever else
um
so so anyway that a few thoughts there
let's see
um
well sort of a question here that from
Aaron that follows on a little bit from
the society question is there a
particular reason that the ability
reason that the ability to reason
evolved in land mammals instead of
reptiles fish Etc I don't think we know
because I don't think we've you know
it's again this question of what are the
whales thinking about you know what are
the Dolphins thinking about
um it looks to us like our forms of
reason and civilization and so on have
certainly Arisen Among Us land animals
so to speak but I don't think we know
for sure that the culture of the whales
you know could be culture of the whales
could be really pretty pretty good for
all we know those whale songs could be
you know maybe they're a few thousand
years behind in terms of of um sort of
where Society is and civilization is for
humans but maybe maybe not more than
that or maybe they're
totally different and they're they're
just Mindless whistling so to speak
um we just don't really know
well let's see
uh
huh
that's a um okay let's see
that's a very different questions here
so I'm trying to pick some variety well
Paul asks why are some physical
constants dimensionless
okay this is we're now going to dive
into a completely different area of of
uh human or scientific endeavor
so
let's talk about units
let's talk about dimensions
you say something is two feet long two
meters long
something lasts two seconds
something has a speed of 3 meters per
second
there's a there's a number there a three
but then there's a unit that tells you
sort of how you should be
[Music]
um
how that
what how to interpret that number
why are there physical units why is it
the case that it is a different kind of
thing to talk about a length than a Time
I think in the end
it kind of relates to the way that we as
humans perceive things
in how to say this I think
that
when we are talking about length for
example
we are imagining you know comparing the
length of a thing like I remember I
think in Magna Carta it says one inch is
the length of the king's thumb or
something uh I'm not sure if that
survived very long in British law but um
uh it was that way in 1200 or something
like that but in other words there's a
there's a length and we can compare sort
of this physical uh this physical
extension to something about us and our
bodies and so on and similarly when
there's a time there's a certain
experience that we have for that period
of time and these are distinct things
length and time for example
now
uh
it gets
gosh
it's this is a little complicated
actually
um
one of the questions is what are the
fundamental
uh dimensions
that are relevant to things like for
example length
is a dimension but volume is not a
separate Dimension volume is derived
from length a volume is like the cube of
a length you've got you know
width depth height type thing and those
three together determine volume and so
volume is not an independent
Dimension from length it's like length
cubed and so the question arises well
what are the independent dimensions of
of kind of uh the physical world and
what's usually been
um identified Mass length time these are
uncontroversial ones then it gets a
little bit more controversial then this
amount of substance the number of atoms
measured in moles another one there's
luminous intensity measured in in
Candela in in the in the uh nks units in
the in SI unit system the standard
metric unit system and that's
essentially the number of photons that
uh exist in some in some case
and then
what am I forgetting there's uh
uh well some people think that angle is
a separate kind of unit of measure from
uh length and so on and oh yeah another
one people sometimes talk about is bits
of information
that that's a sort of independent unit
of independent non-convertible
dimensional thing about the world but
all the other kinds of things like you
know acceleration is some length time to
the minus two or you know force uh or
energy is
um uh energy is uh Mass length squared
divided by times squared
um and that many things that you might
think you might think energy is a very
different kind of thing from length and
time and so on but actually there's a
way of representing energy in terms of
mass length time and so on Okay so
it really depends on what you think is
sort of fundamental in the world how
many really independent things there are
so for example the speed of light
converts length and time so the speed of
light says you know in one nanosecond in
one billionth of a second light travels
about a foot so in a sense once you have
the speed of light as kind of a a
constant as a as a thing that you know
is out there then time and length become
in a sense immediately interconvertible
and in a sense you don't really need a
separate notion of dimensions of length
and dimensions of time once you say oh
there's the speed of light as well
and there are uh in
in standard physics there are several
quantities that are kind of uh these
converters so speed of light converts
length and time uh there's also the
gravitational constant uh the the thing
that determines the strength of gravity
that converts uh let's see it's a that's
a more complicated set of units but that
essentially converts Mass
um and uh yeah in the end because it
determines the curvature of space it
relates mass and length and the
gravitational constants relates mass and
length and a third thing is Planck's
constant a kind of fundamental constant
determining the the uh the way quantum
mechanics works and that relates
um
uh
energy well it's it has units of um
energy times time
um but it it is a it gives you relations
between essentially things like energy
and time
um
so in a sense once you kind of
these constants like the speed of light
and so on you can
yeah and if if you as a human say my
unit of length is a meter that's what I
relate to as a human my unit of time is
a second that's what I relate to as
humor as a human then the speed of light
is a thing you measure about the world
but
there's a sense in which the speed of
light is just a way of defining those
units it's not really a thing you
measure about the world it just says
given that you've got a certain
Elementary time length time unit for
example the speed of light is just the
conversion factor that goes from that to
the elementary length unit
so it's an interesting question in our
model of physics
where these dimensional quantities
really come from and because in the end
in our model of physics everything that
exists in the universe is just some
whole collection of elements in these
hypographs that are being Rewritten
etc etc etc that everything is
ultimately just a piece of computational
data and so how could there ever be some
sort of meaningful physical dimension of
a thing
I think in our models there really is at
some level we have to say well there are
these updates that are happening to this
network that represents the universe how
quickly are those updates happening well
um we could say the updates happen when
they happen and we are observers
embedded within that system and we're
getting updated too and there's nothing
to say about how quickly the updates
happen but we can also say if we look
from outside the system and we imagine
that there's an absolute clock ticking
we can say how quickly do those updates
happen relative to our sort of absolute
clock that we've set up and then we can
start talking about an elementary time
maybe it's 10 to the minus 100 seconds
or something that is this sort of
Elementary clock ticking time for the
universe
this is a complicated area actually of
understanding the uh where where
dimensionality comes from where
this notion of things you can measure
because you know in our models something
like Mass it's just a counting of the
number of of things that are happening
in this network length there's just a
accounting of the number of edges in
this network time is just a counting of
the number of updates that happen in
this network so how can it be the case
that there is a a sense of there being
sort of a a unit a thing that isn't just
a number that is our sort of
representation of a length or something
I think maybe the way to think about it
is this that within the system
there are uh we are embedded within the
system we're made up of these same sort
of atoms of space and so on and uh one
question is how many atoms of space are
there in a typical human maybe the
answer is 10 to 100 let's say
um so and and somehow
that number
is what somehow turns itself into
what we're doing effectively by talking
about meters and seconds and so on is
where we're factoring out having to
actually know that number we're just
saying in a human a human is about a
meter tall we could say a human is 10 to
the 100 uh you know Elementary lengths
tall but we don't know that number so
we're instead we're sort of factoring
that out and we're inventing this kind
of symbolic unit of a meter and saying
we're about a meter tall and so we never
have to discuss we never have to know
what the actual number of of Elementary
lengths that we are is
now
in in traditional physics there are
certain combinations of quantities with
units and so on which are
dimensionalists in the sense that they
are just numbers just like I'm
describing in some sense in our models
of physics everything is just numbers
there are things where we already know
they're just numbers a pretty famous one
is a thing called Define structure
constant but in general a fine
structural constant measures essentially
the strength of electromagnetism
um every
uh pretty much every
um
theory that involves the interaction of
particles
that has the property of being that it
has certain nice mathematical properties
it's a renormalizable theory in Quantum
field Theory all of those theories have
dimensionalists so-called coupling
constants a coupling constant measures
essentially the strength of interaction
between particles so you'd say if you've
got two particles and they're colliding
and you ask what's the probability that
they actually scatter each other as
opposed to just zoom past like particles
you know ships passing in the night
particles just not having an effect on
each other what's the chance that they
actually have an effect on each other
rather than not that's proportional to
the coupling constant so-called coupling
constant and for different theories
whether it's Quantum chromodynamics or
Quantum electrodynamics or something
else there'll be different values of
those coupling constants but those
things in certain kinds of nice
mathematical theories tend to be
dimensionless things and so that's an
example and they're just saying what's
the probability of this interaction
happening so those are examples of where
you get sort of dimensionless quantities
that arise in in standard physics
um curiously the gravitational one is
not dimensionless and that produces all
kinds of complicated tentacles
um about the theory but it's an
interesting question I I you know
actually there's there's probably more
to figure out about sort of the way that
dimensional quantities arise but I think
my basic answer
um there that um
really dimensions are introduced in a in
a theory like ours where everything is
ultimately computational and ultimately
just counting that dimensions are a way
of sort of bulk sort of representing you
know the size of a human is and then
it's a thing like a meter rather than
saying it's the number 10 to the 100 and
so on by the way in our in our Theory
there there really is just one sort of
truly dimensional thing you have to nail
down it's either the elementary length
the elementary time a thing we call the
maximum entanglement speed which is the
analog of the speed of light in
branchial space for quantum mechanics
um but these are any one of those things
would sort of nail down all the other
parameters and and determine them
let's see
the uh yeah I might just comment just
for for interest about about the whole
idea of Dimensions let's talk about a
little bit
um
let me just clarify one thing by the way
um
oh gosh I forgot I'm so embarrassed I
forgot two important uh
um fundamental Dimensions um that exist
charge and temperature are two other
ones
but you see they're all a bit flaky
because
what is charge charge is basically a
count of the number of electrons the
number of electric charges you have just
like luminous intensity is a count of
the number of photons you have and uh
just like
um amount of substance as a count of the
number of atoms or molecules you have
those are just counts of things in a
sense they seem like very fake units
because they're really just counting
things
and um uh you know they're not something
which is some has some different
existence not just accounting now
temperature again another complicated
one because temperature is one where
temperature is the average kinetic
energy the average energy of each
sort of degree of possible motion of an
atom or something it's again it's not
really an independent thing it's really
something which once you know the
structure of a system you kind of know
that you know the energy per unit volume
of the system uh divided by the number
of degrees of freedom and so on is
essentially the temperature
so
and even though in kind of the usual way
of setting up unit systems for the last
I don't know 50 70
100 years people have said temperature
that's a fundamental unit
that's it it starts to look a little bit
flaky when you start realizing well
what's this thing made of underneath
um you know it doesn't look as
independent as you might think now you
know units are very complicated area in
in Wolf malfo we have kind of the an
awesome language we have kind of the
worlds of by far I would say best most
organized way of handling units and and
best sort of curated collection of units
to about 10 000 kinds of units that
people discuss uh about different kinds
of things and there are units that are
you know the amount of the perceived
amount of sound measured in fonts for
example or well my all-time favorite
unit is moles per acre which is a unit
of soil aeration where uh moles is is a
chemical unit of amount of substance but
in this particular case it doesn't mean
that it means the number of Little
Critters who are you know digging up the
soil and aerating it the number of those
per unit area measured in in acres
um
it's uh there are about 10 000 of these
different kinds of units they all
ultimately can be written in terms of
five or six or so of these Mass length
time but ultimately even those can be
written as soon as you have a theory of
physics those get to be written in terms
of even even less and ultimately in
terms of almost nothing now you know
units are really complicated like for
example just a few days ago we were
talking about temperature units and uh
one of the things that's an issue is if
you have uh temperatures the you always
talk about degrees Centigrade degrees
Fahrenheit why are you talking about
that well it's because
it is not an absolute those are not
absolute temperatures those are what
you're talking about okay
so
temperature
is essentially the
um
the temperature measures the average
energy
per degree of Freedom so when you have
the temperature of a gas for example is
determined by the average energy that
all those gas molecules are whizzing
around knowing that they can be going in
the X Direction the y direction the Z
Direction and so on knowing that they
can be spinning around things like this
the the formula is a half KT where K is
Boltzmann's constant T is the
temperature that's the average energy
per degree of Freedom per you move in
this direction you spin around you do
this or that
um and uh but when people measure
temperature
they usually are measuring the
difference in temperature between the
difference between sort of the energy
the gas has uh when it's got this much
heat in it and the energy the gas has
when it has this much heat in it now
there is the notion of absolute zero
minus
273.16 degrees Centigrade
um that's uh the that's the point at
which essentially all of that motion
pretty much stops that's the point at
which you've kind of there's there's no
and that's an absolute temperature but a
lot of what's actually measured and what
people discuss are temperature
differences and confusingly there
haven't been really good notations for
the temperatures versus temperature
differences and so we just introduced
actually we'll be coming in in a wolf
Alpha and a woven language very soon a
little notation with the Delta for
representing difference in temperatures
because the difference in temperatures
is a kind of quantity that you handle in
a different way from an absolute
temperature so to speak there are
computations you can do with with the
temperature differences different from
the computations you can do with an
absolute temperature you know I just to
mention dimensional analysis this is the
somewhat mysterious area of kind of um
uh I don't know what physics or
something
um you know if you're trying to work out
okay the famous example
is this let's say you've got a model
airplane
and you've got a real airplane
and the question is the model airplane
is you want to know
in order to get the same kind of pattern
of airflow over the model airplane and
over a great big real airplane what
should the ratio of the speeds of those
things be is there a is there a speed
for the model airplane and for the real
airplanes such that the pattern of
airflow over those two things will be
the same even though there are very
different scales and so it turns out you
can work that out using dimensional
analysis that means there are only
certain quantities that can matter the
speed of the airplane can matter the the
density of the air can matter the
viscosity the flowiness of the air can
matter the size of the plane can matter
so it turns out that if you take those
quantities and those are the only ones
that matter then you can package those
up only basically in one way into a
dimensionalist object a thing called the
Reynolds number and so what you then
realize is you can scale the viscosity
there the speed the length and so on you
can scale those in different ways if you
press Reserve this Reynolds number
quantity then you'll get the same
overall pattern of flow and so there are
a few nice examples where
um where this where this works out well
where you have this idea that that by
pure dimensional analysis by just
knowing what quantities are important
and seeing what mathematical combination
of those is dimensionless that tells you
how those quantities have to scale in
order to get sort of the same the same
uh physical results that that's
those are um
uh there are well there are a modest
number of examples where that works it's
a little bit of a strange thing because
uh basically you have to know what
quantities are important in determining
how a system behaves and what's a bit
surprising is as soon as you say oh and
there's an extra quantity that might be
important it kind of blows up the
possibility of doing this kind of
numerical this dimensional analysis it's
a case where the more you know the less
you can figure out so to speak and you
know when you have just oh it's only
these four quantities that matter you
can conclude things about dimensional
analysis probably the most famous in the
wild I think this is a this is a real
story
um I I've been told that by several
people including uh at least one or two
who are there
um that um the uh
when the first um
um
atomic bomb test explosion uh was done
in in 1945 the um
uh it was a physicist called GI Taylor
um who was there who um uh was trying to
figure out just how strong was this
explosion how big was the explosion and
you could figure that out there were
certain quantities about the size of the
Fireball and the this and that thing and
um so famously uh GI Taylor used
dimensional analysis sort of in real
time so to speak to try and figure out
uh you know how many kilotons was the
explosion so to speak
um and that was a that's a famous
example of dimensional analysis I have
to say it was also involved in at that
time people were concerned but if you
detonate a nuclear explosion in the
Earth's atmosphere that you might ignite
the atmosphere that you might uh
basically start a process where the
atmosphere just starts burning
everything so to speak and um it was an
analysis a bit like that dimensional
analysis which led the physicists who
were working on this to conclude that no
it won't ignite the atmosphere probably
to uh to detonate a nuclear explosion
I'm not sure in today's World well I
don't know some some very silly things
happen in today's world but I don't know
whether
um whether people would again have the
nerve to actually detonate a nuclear
explosion given that at the time it
really wasn't I think completely clear
it was there were pretty good arguments
that wouldn't ignite the atmosphere but
it certainly wasn't known for sure
because after all nobody had ever nobody
people don't imagine that there's ever
been a nuclear explosion in the Earth's
atmosphere
um before the ones produced by humans
um starting in the 1940s
well
let's see
um
that's a nice story from uh
thy Lord here speaking of strange units
as I said it was an operating system
that required time to be specified in
micro fortnites because although it's
valued
the second and seconds is close to one
It forced the administrator to think
about what they were doing when setting
the system time that's rather nice
um
let's see uh oh yeah I I should just
explain
one one confusion of language here when
I'm talking about dimensions
yeah this is a collision of different
things there's Dimensions as in uh you
know XYZ height
um you know going up sideways you know
left right up down you know and out type
thing
um that's a notion
well let's see
that's that's the three dimensions of
space where we're talking about
dimensions in which we are kind of
saying
these things are related Concepts but
they're not the same there's there's
kind of the the
ways in which we can move around and the
different ways in which we can move
around this other notion of Dimension
that I've been acting about for a while
here is a notion that is about uh units
of measure and and kinds of
uh Dimension as in we are I don't know
how to say this this is a very confusing
thing actually
um you know it's like we've got the mass
of something and that is a a dimension
of the thing as its mass but it's not
dimension in the same sense as we're
talking about three dimensions of space
um and uh someone's commenting here
dimensionality versus versus units yes
that's right I mean that's the it's the
dimensionality of space but
unfortunately the word Dimension gets
used it's not a completely different use
because it is that space has three
dimensions like three length Dimensions
so to speak and one time you know space
time has one time Dimension
um but it's it's um uh the the notion is
a little bit different from these from
these way of of doing units
um
all right I think I have to go to
Something Different Here although there
are lots of very interesting questions
um
that have come in here
um and uh
uh
William asks a question does empty space
have an entropy
um and um as a matter of fact I've been
thinking about that very question
because I've been thinking about the
foundations the second law of
Thermodynamics and the answer to that is
yes it does have an entropy and there
are particular cases in which that's
very measurable when there are black
holes but I think you can think of it
having an entropy at all times and I
think there's a very interesting
relationship between that and the way
gravitational fields work and maybe
we'll talk about that another time
um all right I should wrap up here for
now and um thanks for those interesting
questions and I look forward to seeing
you in our time and uh bye for now